mobilisation en france pour demander la
suspension de la réforme de l'assurance
chômage dans la capitale le départ du
cortège se fait depuis le théâtre de
l'odéon direction le louvre
manifestation à lyon ou encore à
besançon sur l'appel de plusieurs
syndicats et de la coordination des
intermittents et précaires
ils dénoncent tous une réforme injuste
et pointe du doigt le nouveau mode de
calcul des allocations un cortège dans
lequel on retrouve notre reporter
gaiement rosie
bonjour guillemant alors comment ça se
passe actuellement est bien beaux jours
à venir à des écoutes et le cortège
devrait s'élancer d'ici quelques
instants quelques minutes mieux que le
théâtre de l'odéon lui est toujours
occupée et puis vous l'avez dit puis
vous le voyez certainement derrière moi
vous voyez les banderoles derrière moi
les manifestants présents ici demande le
retrait de la réforme de cette ouverture
ans au chômage qui doit entrer en
application le 1er juillet prochain
alors hier matin sept syndicats parmi
lesquels la cgt et cfe cgc la cfdt ou
encore fo ont déposé un recours en
référé devant le conseil d'état exaspère
la suspension voire carrément
l'annulation de cette réforme de
l'assurance chômage par la plus haute
juridiction administrative
alors les intermittents et en théorie ne
sont en théorie je le répète pas
concernée au premier titre par cette
réforme de l'assurance-chômage vous le
savez certainement le rot les indemnités
sont calculés différemment jeu celle des
salariés du régime général il reste que
beaucoup de salariés des intérimaires
des extras ou encore les saisonniers eux
seront bien impactés par cette réforme
très fortement d'ailleurs impactés par
cette réforme de l'assurance-chômage
tous ces travailleurs précaires que l'on
nomme parfois les ter mi temps et ils
sont très nombreux à travailler dans le
monde de la culture justement aux côtés
des intermittents et d'ailleurs amira
j'appelle vos téléspectateurs à revoir à
voir ou à revoir ci ne l'ont pas vu le
sujet de katia technique sur cette
réforme de l'assurance chômage qui est
déjà passée dans dans sept ans
jt ce matin et donc les manifestants
présents ici qu'il s'agisse d'un tamis
temps où justement d'autres d'autres
salariés précaires demande le retrait de
cette réforme de l'assurance chômage
merci guillaume se retrouvent de toutes
façons lors de notre prochaine édition